hi there um welcome to the final panel
session today of the spectators cop 26
comment summit uh we have been
discussing a range of topics when it
comes to bringing together political and
business leaders to look at how to live
in that zero by 2050 what the challenges
are and hopefully what the solutions are
um i'm katie balls i'm deputy political
editor of the spectator and today's
discussion is centering on green and
global trade so ahead of cop 26 boris
johnson's team are going green
we've had calls to slash tariffs on
green goods and whole countries
accountable for heavily polluting
practices
and we're also seeing britain start to
reopen after covert 19. so is the
rhetoric going to match the reality are
plans for global britain going to take
off and in that case is the green agenda
going to become a dominant feature of
our trade negotiations of a trade policy
or a sideline strategy and is it going
to be a help or a hindrance
and so what does britain have to offer
as trading partners when it comes to
negative emissions and boosting global
recovery and i think one of the things
we're keen to talk about is is a carbon
border adjustment mechanism going to be
something which has helped to this um
now before we begin before we go any
further i want to thank you say thank
you to our partner drax for sponsoring
today's panel and also say we're going
to try and take as many questions as
possible and keen to make it very
interactive um
we're going to have some open remarks uh
but if people have any questions come to
mind at any point um you can ask the
question by typing in the text box on
the spectator tv site or by emailing
events.spectator.com
that's events at spectator.com
and i'm gonna try and get through as
many as possible i do know um when it
comes to discussions like this it can
get quite techy quite quickly uh so we
will go and we will dive into the detail
but if you can try and keep your
questions obviously it's accessible
because you've got a mix of people
they're involved in this session that
would be great otherwise i will then
attempt to break things down um and with
that i want to introduce our esteemed
panel uh we'll be running till 1pm no
later and so discussing the topics i've
just raised we have been full army empty
pitchers and harpington parliamentary
private secretary to the secretary of
state for work and pensions he's chair
of the all parliamentary group for
renewable energy and sustainable energy
as well as the co-chair and net zero
champion for the all parliamentary group
on fair business banking along with many
other roles uh we also have matthew fell
chief uk policy adviser at the cbi
matthew joined the
cbi in 1999 and has covered a range of
business sectors including manufacturing
small business and financial services so
it brings a depth of knowledge to this
discussion and then we have claire
harbor group director of corporate
affairs with drax and in this role she
also has responsibility for
sustainability regulation policy and
compliance
and then finally last but not least we
have eamonn ives head of energy and
environment at the center for policy
studies his research tends to focus on
market-based solutions to environmental
challenges and with that i'm going to
kick things off by going to each of our
speakers for opening remarks around
three minutes i'll be looking at my
clock and we then have a few questions
and i'm going to begin by asking bim to
talk
great well thank you and it's a it's a
pleasure to be here and join you
so
what is trade really about trade is
really about when you get underneath all
the the techie language and all the
all the uh the detail
it's really about when you are good at
something
selling that service or product to a
country or a place
where they are less good at it in their
own country and thereby
ensuring yourself being
prosperous and indeed
improving the lives of people in that
country
on the green agenda if we are successful
with embedding
the net zero ambition within our economy
and i put this as
a way of effectively reindustrializing
parts of the uk that maybe have suffered
over the last 20 30 40 years if we're
successful in doing that it will
be an inherently strong part of our
trade offer when it comes to dealing
with other countries and so i think
that's what we need to try and achieve
though we're not there yet areas where
this might be the case we may talk about
them
renewable energy wind power solar power
indeed nuclear energy and we may talk
about that as well
hydroelectric other types of energy and
indeed hydrogen carbon capture and
storage the sorts of technologies that
are critical if we're going to achieve
net zero by 2050. these are all things
that i think the uk is increasingly
proving its success at other countries
in the world are going to be making the
same sort of uh
same sort of uh obligations trying to
achieve the same sort of things in
relation to net zero that we're trying
to achieve here in this country
we can help them do that if
we put this at the forefront of our
trade agenda it's something that i'm
sure i hope that the government's going
to do in the months and years to come
brian thank you vim and now i'm going to
go to matthew um
for your opening remarks
brilliant well uh thanks everyone great
to uh great to join you here today uh
look just sort of three thoughts for me
to to help set the scene i think uh one
would just be why do we think this is
such a big part of the uk's economic
future second how do we really go about
seizing the opportunity and then third
what does that mean for international
trade prospects in our approach
so the uk's economic future look just at
the cbi we've recently completed a big
piece of work around what is the uk's
economic future for the next 10 years
and it was really prompted by a sense
that we've just got an opportunity to do
things differently a bit of a once in a
generation opportunity actually coming
off the back of brexit covid the pace of
technology and of course the net zero
imperative throws things up in the air a
little bit and gives us a chance to
think where is growth coming from but
also how do we commit to better growth
that build back better agenda
and in doing
what we've done is looked at where where
really can the uk compete and win so
it's highly ambitious but also rooted in
reality and we've identified half a
dozen opportunities or prizes that the
uk can chase down and decarbonization
quite clearly is one of those and a bit
of a no-brainer
when we did this piece of work we looked
at it through lots of different lenses
so individuals in society all businesses
and then specific firms and sectors and
there's winds in it for everything so
for individuals clearly
we think there's a big job creation
story in here for the uk as well as
better air quality in there for better
living standards but also for all
businesses it makes them much more
attractive to customers to talent lowers
the cost of capital
and so on and then we come on to the
international agenda because if you
happen to play in one of these markets
offshore wind hydrogen carbon capture
electric vehicles nuclear and so on real
opportunities to win there and establish
the uk as a leading net
exporter but as bill has just said
actually
where do he seize the opportunity
because the uk is not alone in thinking
this so we need urgency and pace to get
on with the agenda and for my money i
think it's really important that we're
strong domestically on all of these
things in order to be able to win
internationally so you won't find i
suspect many if anyone at all in the
industry who uh has much to argue with
in the government's ten point plan
around net zero actually it's great
stuff the ambition and the vision is
spot on it's all now about filling in
the gaps so on green buildings can we
get that comprehensive heat and building
strategy on carbon capture can we
confirm the new business models on the
shift to electric vehicles can we get
the gigafactories in place in time it's
all about getting those details in place
so that we can invest behind it
and then to close from me just the
international trade and the prospects
look we completely need to gear up for
success in all of these things and
actually in order to play to the uk's
strengths i think because we've got in
the uk not just the innovative products
and the technical capability but also
our services industry know how so if we
can get that locked together that's a
brilliant export right around the world
to go about how do you go about
decarbonizing
industrialized economies and so on cop
later this year clearly is a major
opportunity to showcase the uk
so what we really want to do is create a
race to the top showcase how british
businesses are leading the charge and
then help to drive some of those
domestic and global policy outcomes that
will help us lead the way so i think
organizations like the cbi that we've
just recently got together around the g7
with some of our sister federations
around the world and tackled and lent
into some of those harder to address
issues coal for hard to obey sectors
carbon pricing thorny issues but if we
can get some international consensus on
those it really teases up for success so
that's it for me katie i think look got
to be strong domestically to win
internationally don't assume it will
just happen by accident we really need
the detail place and momentum behind it
and then let's shape the international
agenda in a way that gears up the uk for
success
brilliant thank you matthew and claire
hi good morning everybody great to be
here um
as as others have said this is a
critical turning point uh in climate
change and we're in a really important
time for the uk we've got this fantastic
opportunity of cop to really showcase
the global leadership that we have uh in
tackling climate change we're very proud
at drax a british company to play a key
part in that and we have transformed the
uk's biggest coal fire power station in
north yorkshire to become europe's
biggest decarbonization project and we
are very very proud that we are in doing
so enabling the uk to meet its climate
change targets so by converting coal to
sustainable
biomass we've actually protected
thousands of jobs in the north uh and
particularly in the humber and we've
kept the lights on across the uk and now
we're looking forward to our next great
uh innovation and we can make an even
more valuable contribution to climate
change you may not have heard about
negative emissions before but this will
be impossible to reach net zero without
the technologies that deliver negative
emissions and experts in the climate
change committee agree that if we don't
do something about net zero and remove
carbon emissions we are not going to
reach our targets so at drax we spent
many years developing industrial scale
negative emissions technology which is
bioenergy with carbon capture and
storage is called bex and we are shovel
ready we are making uh partnerships with
with um big international companies like
the japanese we are ready to complete
this pioneering project which will be
the world's largest carbon capture
project
in the world and we are ready we are
ready to go and we are looking forward
to the government providing some
investment frameworks and support
that we would need just like wind really
took off when the government gave it
that support just like the french did
with nuclear not only can we really
boost this technology and lead the world
we can also export it across the world
and help other nations really reduce
their carbon emissions so we're really
excited about these new technologies
we're really excited about negative
emissions and in fact next week we are
launching a coalition of negative
emissions with a report from mckinsey to
show just how critical
investment is in these negative
emissions technology which needs to be
scaled up urgently the price is huge
absolutely huge and we've got fantastic
opportunities for jobs protecting heavy
industries in the north creating new
green jobs and we stand ready to invest
so we are ready on a global stage and
our ambitions don't stop there we are
also working with bechtel and
identifying new opportunities to build
becks elsewhere across the world so
we're ready to rock we're ready for
negative emissions and we're really
looking forward let's announce this at
cop let's get on with it and show the
global leadership that uk plc has got
for the world in this critical issue of
addressing climate change
thanks
thank you claire and now let's go to
eamon for the final opening remarks
thank you katie pleasure to be here um
so my remarks i'm actually going to
concentrate on something you alluded to
in your introduction um namely the
fiendishly named carbon border
adjustment mechanisms which i'm going to
call sea bans for short um so for the
uninitiated seabans help to tackle
climate change by essentially making
polluters responsible for the costs of
the emissions they create i know
something which i think the government
should be focusing on a lot more than it
currently is especially as we run up to
cop26
um so they essentially work by applying
charge on emissions uh sorry on imports
which have not already accounted cost of
their emissions in the countries where
they were originally made um and i think
the ukc ban would be an extremely
powerful tool tool um to persuade other
governments to adopt climate policies
which are as ambitious the ones that we
have here in the uk and should be proud
of having
um i think one of the best ways to think
about it is to consider say the
following example
imagine you're a chinese steel exporter
and you're now facing an extra charge to
send your products to the uk because of
the new sea bam
so how do you think the chinese
government might react to that well they
might just you know decide to let
businesses take the tariff on the chin
pay it and we will move on or they might
decide that they'd rather have um the
revenue of that cbam instead of going to
hmrc they'd quite like to have it for
themselves which they're perfectly
entitled to if they wrote enact a robust
carbon price of their own
um and then what that would do is when
we have that carbon price in place is
that the whole economy then has an
impetus to avoid paying it by switching
to cleaner technologies which are less
reliant on fossil fuels if at all
um so in this sense i think of cbam is
something that we can certainly adopt at
home um but we can use it to hasten
decarbonization everywhere
and setting one up certainly won't be
easy but i think it's perfectly possible
and it's always better to be roughly
right than precisely wrong um i also
think it will be remiss not to consider
the current political dynamics around
sea bams so if we look over to europe we
can see the eu is really striding ahead
here um should soon be setting out its
top-level thoughts and what one should
look like similarly in america joe
biden's made some overtures of them in
the past um so to my mind the kind of
direction is inevitable um and so to not
be part of that conversation
really risks the uk seeding a lot of the
good climate leadership capital which
has managed to build up in recent years
through you know the climate change act
net zero all of that
um so so yeah my plea to government is
to really sort of get involved on these
you know start joining the conversation
joining the debate because i think it's
as i say i think the direction is
inevitable and it would be um
potentially difficult for us to be
bounced into something later down the
line um so yeah uh to wrap up in
conclusion i think that a sebam is kind
of necessary so that when we're saying
we decarbonizing we can be confident
that we genuinely are um instead of just
pushing our pollution elsewhere which
could be the case as we ramp up climate
action going forwards
brilliant thank you very much even i'm
looking forward to chewing those
thoughts over the panel uh as as we go
on and it's definitely as you say one of
the areas that that doesn't yet to be
seen to be agreement so just before we
get to that i thought to begin i mean
bim in your opening remarks you were
talking about how the fact that when we
step away after talking about how we
incorporate a green uh trade you know
green agenda of our trade policy it
openly comes to what does the uk have
that can help other countries and i
wanted to maybe uh go to you matthew to
ultimately say what do you think the
biggest biggest assets are right now
when it comes to the uk and that green
revolution when it comes to what we're
going to have in negotiations in the
future
do you want me to have a first crack
yeah
i mean look i think in terms of the uk's
biggest assets i think it's for me it's
kind of really why we need to just get
pace and momentum in this agenda i think
one of our biggest assets look we've got
a real opportunity in a shade under six
months time now with cop26 to just be
putting the uk completely on the world
stage and showing the way as we were
able to do recently with the g7
and that for me i think is the biggest
thing that we can play in our hand if we
can get the most paced momentum in
making progress right now to be able to
say
look the uk is on this it's not easy but
we're on it and then to be able to
demonstrate that to the rest of the
world i think that is the most powerful
and most persuasive way when we're
looking to secure international
agreements shape trade policies shape
regulation and so on you kind of got to
be on the front foot uh as the home
nation if you were to be able then to
put through power of persuasion but also
demonstration to be able to bring others
on board too so that for me would be the
thing we've got to be leading from the
front from the uk in order to be able to
bring others with us on the journey
ben
yeah i mean look
leading's very very important and cop 26
gives us an opportunity to do that but i
think that really
we have to be quite precise about the
areas in which the uk
is better and better in a technical
sense than most other countries i pick
one main two main areas one is
technology and science
the vaccine rollout though a different
subject has shown and reminded the world
how good we are at science with our top
universities
and i think we need to be doubling down
on that sort of work and showing that in
a climate change context
and that applies to all sorts of
renewable energy requires the carbon
capture and storage like um we were
hearing about drugs it applies to lots
of different things but i think that
needs to be a focus and the second thing
is the city of london now i'm prejudiced
because i worked in the city before i uh
became an mp but
the city of london combined
combined with technical scientific
ability to come up with new technologies
those two things combined there are very
few if other if any other countries that
can do that and i think that that is
what we need to be selling not just
leading from the front but more more
specifically saying we have a unique
combination and ecosystem that nobody
else has we're going to now take that to
other countries
claire do you agree with that i mean i
think technology i mean we can talk
about cc us as well
so carbon capture and storage and
aspects of this it just feels like
that's somewhere where the uk could have
a lot of momentum when it comes to
technology and also obviously it links
to things like electric cars and so
what's your take
um absolutely i mean you know the great
thing is the uk leads the world to
renewable energies i mean look at the
fantastic story of wind and solar i mean
we literally lead the world we are
leading in terms of renewable power
coming coming from non-fossil fuel
sources and again you know at drax we
have come off coal-fired uh power
stations the the the uk is leading the
world in coming off fossil fuels so so
we are actually doing it and in these in
terms of these new technologies we're
not just talking about it we are
actually doing them we are doing this at
drax and as being said you know we're
working with academics as well that's
all been part and we have got real
tangible commercial partnerships now
we're not talking about them we've just
done a deal with the japanese so this is
real all we need now is the regulatory
frameworks and off we go just like
winded i mean so we are we are ready and
when i sit with colleagues from other
energy industries we stand ready to
invest we're not just talking about it
we are ready to go and i do hope that
these big international companies if you
can't if you're not given the signals
from government to invest here they will
take their capital somewhere else so
we've got a unique opportunity the
clocks ticking so let's make the most of
cop and really demonstrate that we we
can do this stuff and and we can we can
do it we are doing it now let's just get
on with it
and claire just on that you mentioned
wind power i mean we i think we all will
here remember the prime minister's
speech about you know making britain the
saudi arabia of wind power yes
cheating is that type of big kind of
gesture kind of a force from the
government we need to get some of this
stuff going yes particularly on things
like carbon capture we could lead the
world we could export this technologies
we could do it all over the world we can
help other countries from drax you know
help come off coal which is the huge
emissions emitter all of these huge
company countries in the world uh need
to come off these fossil fuels so these
new technologies to reduce negative
emissions are absolutely the way forward
and uk plc has got the lead so so let's
let's do it
and now we're getting a nice range of
questions already coming in and so
please do keep that um but just to
remind you how to do so uh you could
obviously email
events.spectator.com or ask a question
by typing into the text box i'm going to
come to some of those um shortly um
ayman i just wanted to come to you
briefly um ultimately when it comes to i
suppose promoting low-carbon trade uh
you previously suggested that
you need to remove barriers and tariffs
so
is that the type of intervention that
you think we need from the government uh
what do you think be the most powerful
thing oh that's really obviously it's
investment so
definitely yeah i think um
on the whole sort of tariff question um
and to give the government its credit i
think it has done a good job on this so
if we're having this event maybe a year
ago i'd have you know less encouraging
things to say but um the sort of the
introduction of the uk global tariff i
think liz trust has done a very good job
in terms of cutting the amount of
tariffs and the simplicity around them
on a lot of environmental goods and
services there are definitely still
somewhere we can go further so electric
vehicles brings to mind uh bicycles
things like that i just you know i don't
see a good reason at all for having
tariffs on a lot of goods but
particularly ones they're going to help
lower the cost of the transition to a
net zero economy so if uh you know bim
and his colleagues can put the pressure
on there to get that kind of get the job
done on on tariffs application and
lowering um and and also some non-tariff
barriers as well so think around rules
of origin which i know could become
particularly thorny things like electric
vehicles um at least in the eu trade
agreement um certainly that's something
which is absolutely within the gift of
government and and it could just do it
tomorrow if it really wanted to so so
more work there i think would be would
be brilliant
and bim let's talk about a carbon
leakage another another way of
describing that phrase that we were
talking about earlier when it comes to
the idea of a carbon border tax now
eamonn's highlighted already uh you know
stops the arguments for it and i think
that there is a sense if you are going
to sell net zero uh to not just your
domestic audience particularly uk
businesses there has to be a sense that
you are not going to be punished
because other countries can have cheaper
practices you often hear those figures
who are at the most resistant to the net
zero agenda so for example tony abbott
was recently on spectator tv saying one
of his concerns about australia going
faster than they are is you could weaken
uh cert you know economies in the west a
place like china don't follow suit so do
you think uh you know carbon border tax
is something that the prime minister
should support
i think
we should definitely consider it
strongly but i would put
it in two categories
there are countries like china which are
competitors of the highest qua class
and energy and an ability and then you
have
other countries which are significantly
poorer countries
now i don't think we should be treating
china and say a very poor country and
say sub-saharan africa the same way when
it comes to this sort of thing because
actually you know those countries are
different stages of development and even
though their environmental record in
certain instances may be similar i think
all of us would intuitively feel a
certain unfainter unfairness with
treating certain very poor countries in
that way
however
even if we separate those two things out
the key point is this
if we decide to do this without
certain technologies being freely
available or being cost effective for
example in china making steel you know
making industrial amounts i mean no pun
intended industrial amounts of steel
and flooding the world market if it is
not
economically viable for them to produce
steel in a cleaner way
if we are the country that decides to do
that i guarantee you there'll be other
western countries that do not do that
because they will say well hold on our
industry or our country wants
cheaper steel so
even if you separate out the sort of big
polluters and the most economically
successful polluters with the poorer
countries you've still got a lot of
problems in relation to the poorer
countries we need to make sure that
through aid through other mechanisms we
are giving them the ability to be able
to afford the technologies that we're
very excitedly trying to sell all over
the world
eamonn what do you say to that because
clearly one of the problems is
logistically something there's a reason
it's such a new topic we can agree with
the fact that it would fix sorts of
things but it could be very hard to
reach an agreement about perhaps
becoming almost a protectionist ring of
certain countries doing it
certainly yeah and i think that is
probably you know the biggest stumbling
block and it's one that we need to
try delicately around um but also i
think let's not get too bogged down on
it um because i think there are there
are good reasons for this and it's
perfectly i think there's a lot of
precedent at least in wto law that would
allow this and and if we want to make
sure that we're not hammering um you
know the poorest countries which need
sort of the access to free trade the
most then i think we can absolutely take
some measures to to protect them um from
some of the downsides so first of all we
could see which goods we apply it to
straight away um and make sure they're
not too trade exposed with those poorer
countries um the uk already gives i
think uh charity and quota free access
to 46
less developed countries anyway under
wto rules so um so i think there are
some carve outs we can we can do to make
sure that um you know we kind of capture
them at the most amount of benefits from
a carbon border adjustment mechanism
without sort of piling the costs onto
others
matthew do you do you think it's going
to be no
just one extra thought on this for me
would just be to say look it this may
not have its place
i would sort of put above it that push
for this is one of the reasons why we're
just so keen to get as much
international sort of progress and
consensus as possible in terms of the
overall overall sort of framework and so
on and the more you can achieve that for
me
then some of the the border taxis and so
on look they may have a plant to play
but it's sort of lessons and some of the
issues we've just been talking about
they've been and so on
you know those concerns will be moderate
a little bit the more you have that sort
of consensus and consistency of
international approach so i sort of i'd
go for it in a sort of one-two combo
like that sort of thing with the push
for the international rules as much as
possible
yeah and use cop26 as the the place to
really get that going um okay now i'm
going to go to a few audience questions
and then slip a few minutes as we go
also um
claire i think this this one for you
first i think um so andrew asks many
companies like drax and governments like
uk are increasingly taking positive
actions to achieve challenging esg
targets but one of the difficulties is
to measure and prove what they're doing
um and then say blockchain is a perfect
technology solution to create a global
tracking system which would eliminate
the current fuzzy overlapping data you
know double counting and the us is
talking about this is this something
that uk should be talking about
i i think it's really uh interesting i
think it's really important to track
progress et cetera and i think it's a
really interesting idea um and i i think
um you know i i encourage other options
to to look at this so i think it's a
really good idea yes
um and would that be helpful in terms of
i suppose do you think is an issue
almost being able to prove what you're
doing with lots of different you know
double counting and things like that yes
absolutely no i think it's very
important and also to give credibility
um and transparency um to to to
governments and to and to the consumer
absolutely
and now we're talking about obviously
how the screen gen can be wrapped up in
trade deals so luke asks how green is
the recent australia trade deal now this
is the uk's first
bespoke trade deal since uh ultimately
uh leaving the eu it's once actually
made from scratch and i think it's been
interesting because on the uk side
there's definitely some who think
they've had a lot of time actually into
getting various commitments in relation
to cop 26 perhaps not anything that
binding and when uh which i think
depending on who you speak was a good
use of time and obviously maybe they
could have pushed more some other stuff
so uh
i suppose maybe if we go to uh bim first
on that how green do you think the
dealers given that australia often are
criticized for their own coal use
so i think that
you can look at this one of two ways
it is
moving in a green direction so for
example in agriculture the requirements
are over the next 15 years i think so
that's quite a long time there's a lot
of
there's a lot of improvements on both
sides to do in that regard so i think
that it's definitely moving the right
direction on the other hand
we have to be very straightforward about
this australia is a major minerals uh
producer mining
we are not in the same way
so we can't
it's going to be difficult to get
australia to agree to certain things
in the way that we would more easily
agree to them because those sectors in
our economy are very small if not
non-existent
so that's not the way i look at it per
se how i think about this and i need to
look at the detailed provisions on this
and actually i'm getting a detailed
briefing on this later this week is
to what extent when it comes to industry
is australia tying itself to specific
ends
or is it are there commitments they've
made
to
uh to discussing to engaging in a global
way and that's what i'll be looking at
and i don't know the answer to that at
the moment
claire i don't ask you about it i mean
on that topic i mean the international
phase out of coal uh as a business touch
on
certain countries are going to find that
easier in terms of what they're
interested in australia is one that is
going to find it harder but you're
talking about how the uk can
lead and uk companies can ultimately
leave that standard so do you think
that's actually somewhere where the uk
will be able to bring other countries
such as australia on cyber showing that
it's doable here
absolutely i mean you know the the uk
leads in terms of closing down its coal
fire power stations i mean we've got
very very few now we're most almost
entirely on on renewable so we have got
a fantastic story to tell and you know
at drax we are very open to sharing that
um expertise and knowledge um
across the world we we lead the world i
mean we're the only coal fire power
station that has absolutely transformed
into using bioenergy so we can we can
and we can export that knowledge and
expertise to other countries
particularly the borough countries
and just on that just and alan has asked
him in relation to drax and obviously uh
looking at you he says as burning wood
produces co2 carbon capture and storage
storage is not yet feasible um you know
how is that
maybe better but how is that one so you
know are we all the way there yet do you
mean there's some questions over there
well we we we've been doing the
technology for over a year now we've got
partners where we're all ready to go it
is proven and we have the support and
endorsement of the climate change
committee only last week they published
a report that the bioenergy and carbon
capture is a critical pathway to to
achieving the emissions target for the
uk so we feel very confident that we can
do it
now even we're talking about
market-based solutions and but wilfred i
think is asking a question when it comes
to the cost of net zero
so who is going to meet the cost for
public sector changes um to electric
vehicles and introduction in the
introduction of net zero heating systems
so uh ultimately lots of excitement
around cop26 and i'm going to come to
bim as well on this one uh but there is
there is a question of the eventual
price tag and how this is sold so when
when you're looking at ways i mean you
know solutions to pushing this agenda
through is that one of the areas where
you're a bit uh yeah i think it probably
looks trickier
so on on the public question well i
guess that would be taxpayers ultimately
um
but but yeah i think maybe sort of just
getting to the
gist of the question itself um certainly
there are going to be costs of getting
to net zero and i don't think anybody
disputes that um you know if there
weren't any costs then we probably
wouldn't need to be having this debate
today and
and all the policies that the government
has come out with because um because
that's where it is um but there are a
great deal of cost for not getting there
as well we need to be cognizant of those
um
and i think um another thing to keep
fresh in our mind is that um
you know if we come up with ways of
decarbonizing more effectively and and
more cost effectively that that's better
and and that's sort of where i guess you
know i try and come in with some of the
policies we're recommending um hence
things like cutting tariffs on
environmental goods and services you
know that would lower the cost of
getting to net zero um and and things
like that and um so yeah i think it's
it's a really difficult question and i
must say also that the price tag is
comes down every every year seemingly um
because of the the progress of
technologies they're making i mean look
at offshore wind look at solar panels
batteries for electric vehicles they're
just absolutely tumbled in the last 10
years and i think wover tied anyone who
sort of um you know thinks that it's
going to be
as expensive as we thought it was you
know two years ago when the net zero
target was set i think it's almost
certainly again going to be lower um all
the sort of the forecasts would say that
um um so yeah i don't know what wants to
add anything to that as well yeah um
i'll come to go to bim and then to
matthew and then just you know touching
on that so who's going to pay because i
think it's worth pointing out that when
it comes to that domestic audience we
see lots of polling which says oh people
you know love the green agenda and
actually there isn't for the talk that
it's the hardest out in some areas there
seems to be general enthusiasm but it
does change when you often drove into
the details so if you say well should
the government tell you not to let your
gas for them should you foot the bill
and support does drop quite swiftly and
similarly i think the current cost of
electric cars is something which does
not hold very well if someone had to
change so
who do you think is going to fit the
bill
well what amon said around the cost
dropping is right but i think there's a
bigger problem which is
the practicality of doing certain things
so the big area i think for this is
around heat and buildings
there is no way
of sugar coating if you are going to
have to insulate hundreds of thousands
of buildings that that will be an
invasive thing to do even if you put
costs to one side so
i think that we need to face up to that
in terms of who pays
i think that in order to maintain public
support for this we are going to have
probably that the government is going to
have to pay and ultimately taxpayers for
probably a majority of people
not just the very poorest i think a
majority of people need to be quite
heavily subsidized particularly when it
comes to
heat buildings
electric cars i'm hoping that the market
might do enough work but even if it
doesn't then we may have to provide some
subsidy there and there are other things
as well how i pay for that is by
probably putting levies on whether i'd
know carbon adjustment tax as we've been
talking about or maybe on certain heavy
polluting industries putting levees so
as much as possible the cost is borne by
those who are contributing most of the
problem but i think that we need to be
very honest and say if we want people to
go along with this we are going to have
to make it practically as easy as
possible even when something is invasive
and financially as easy as possible
because if we don't do that politically
for whatever major party
it's going to be incredibly difficult to
get support
matthew
yeah just a few things on that i one uh
i i uh building on what both amen and
bim have just said i think uh firstly i
there is a little bit of a role where
government could lead the way on some of
that retrofit for example around social
housing and so on to really get the sort
of market going uh in that that would be
a helpful thing i uh completely agree
on how do you get the consumer
incentives hooked up behind this as bin
was just saying you know you take my uh
my mother and father are retired
homeowners for example
a position where they probably could do
all of this stuff but what really tips
them over to sort of saying yeah i'm
going to go for it sort of thing so i
think those consumer incentives are
really important as part of this and
then at anything's point look the cost
is coming down on these things so i
think that is where uh the phasing is
really important and it's where bodies
like the committee on climate change and
so on they're completely right to say of
course the sooner you act the less
expensive and the easier it is overall
sort of thing if we're thinking about
this on a 2050 time horizon but also
what should we be really focusing on now
and getting going and then where is the
sort of the moment right you get going
on other stuff i think that sequencing
and phasing is really important too
now i just want to get two questions on
nuclear so i'm just gonna um bring them
up at the same time and then uh go to
this panel so first is charles is
nuclear the only say in energy policy
the electric generation
and then paula since electricity
generation is such a big part of the
problem why don't we just go nuclear
like france and claire if you've got
thoughts on this one
sorry
well
nuclear is not my not not my area of
expertise but i think um i i my general
view is that to have a mix of energy uh
sources and technologies is probably a
good thing to have in terms of security
supply uh and um and and sustainability
um but i think probably matthew and
others have a have a better view about
the ins and outs of the nuclear industry
but it is it's uh it's an interesting uh
dilemma for the government isn't it
security supply against um
sustainability issues and we know that
we have had some issues and some uh
problems with the nuclear fleet so i'd
be interested with other panelists what
their views are yeah and maki
yeah uh
uh violent agreement with what claire
joe said actually i mean i think nuclear
absolutely has a role to play uh as part
of the mix but i would completely pursue
it as a sort of not not all eggs in one
basket kind of approach i think uh being
reasonably technology neutral on this uh
is a good thing
uh with many different sources of supply
but with nuclear completely amongst
those
um now claire one question i wanted to
ask you was um
ultimately we were talking about kind of
exporting net zero about setting an
example to other countries but to what
extent do you think britain needs to get
its own house in order when it comes to
the energy system to be in the the best
place to do that
well i think we can do both and i think
we should do both and i think um as i've
said before you know the energy industry
stan stands ready to invest uh and we we
have lots of fantastic projects lots of
technologies ready to go uh and we are
looking forward to i think this is the
critical year to have some uh policy um
and frameworks to actually get on and do
it i i think this could be a great year
and i would love to see these
announcements at cop
to really show to show the way for for
uk plc
yeah look i'm just going to say on that
couple of thoughts one is uh i think
that is absolutely right but let's be
under no illusion that lots of the
companies who operate in this space do
so in many many countries right around
the world and the uk is sort of
competing for investment that they have
to play i think that many of them are
keen to put it to play in the uk market
but they kind of want those details
filled in to enable them to press go on
the investment otherwise it'll it's in
danger of going elsewhere sort of thing
so i think getting that
regulatory detail to allow companies to
invest is really really important and
then just to sort of illustrate it in a
sense making sure that those prices
don't slip through our fingers uh one of
the easiest things just to visualize and
wrap your head around is electric
vehicles and so on but that is going to
be a major major market uh both in the
uk in europe and right around the world
in the years to come
the uk ought to be pretty well placed
and take advantage of that we've got a
strong uh history and heritage of
automotive manufacturer and so on lots
of the innovation and the technology
that bim was describing in his opening
remarks but the reality is that is
something like probably about an 18
billion export prize over the next
decade but unless we get on and get the
gigafactories uh built in the uk
those prizes are going to slip through
our fingers and they'll go elsewhere now
look that replicates then across loads
of the different types of technologies
but it's just an illustration of we need
to get going now in order to realize the
prices that will flow from that in the
years to come
then
i i agree with that what i
if i may ask of my other panelists is
what is it what are the specific things
that they'd like from government in
relation to whether it be electric
vehicles certain other things to get
this more investment and an fdi coming
into the country because i hear a lot of
sort of we need to do this we need to do
that we're ready but okay what specific
things do people want from government so
i can take them back to my colleagues
when i go to the house later this
afternoon yeah well then i'll let i'll
probably in the chat and drop you a line
if it's okay um
from our side what we've done recently
are
completely designed to be sort of going
with the grain and in the spirit of what
the government's ambitions are around
the 10-point plan which we completely
agree with
and the plan is against each of those
can we feel a little bit more detail so
a good little bit of greed we can send
it through but for people on the line
now i think just to illustrate the point
because i said look on green buildings
that retrofit piece can we have the
comprehensive heat and building strategy
that's been promised let's get that out
even before the summer recess for
example
on carbon capture some of the stuff that
claire was talking about the the actual
business models that companies can
invest against i think the the sort of
the rap model or if it's going to be
that and so on that'd be great and on
the electric vehicles both the delivery
plan for the rollout in the uk as well
as those gigafactories that are a
critical sort of uh enabling technology
and supportive part of the overall
infrastructure those are just three
we've done it again each of the ten
point plan but i'm happy to share that
with people on the line with you and
others but it's kind of i think it's
that thinking and the mentality that we
need to just be on a relentless basis
now in the sort of years to come
we agree with the direction of travel
what are the actions that we need to
take in the next three six twelve months
and if we just have that thought process
going at all times that will be really
sort of impatient and relentless pace
that would chase this down
clara those are type of things you also
like to see is anything you would you'd
add to them
no absolutely
absolutely and and just talking about
carbon capture you know we we just need
the regulatory mechanism that um that
matthew's talk talked about we stand
ready to invest and and as bin will know
too well coming from the city you know
that investment needs signals from
government to give confidence for
investors to to to get the investment
otherwise it goes elsewhere so we need
these really specific signals on
investment and we're ready to go
and eamon i suppose looking to cop 26
it's clearly where ever on this panel
thinks he knows that we're going to
build momentum ahead it's an opportunity
to really show uk leadership um
we think in glasgow unless it goes into
a hybrid form
all the uh uncertainty uncovered um what
do you think are the most important uh
you know announcements commitments that
you would like to see that you think
would really uh change the picture of
where we're going with this
so i think i mean first and foremost um
you know countries coming forward with
stronger and um and yet more ambitious
pledges on what they um want to do for
cutting their own emissions you know
we've already had quite a few of those
um in advance of it and especially when
we thought it was going to be in 2020 um
so china south korea a few other places
um so i think that is you know it's
difficult to look past those as being
the most important things you know we've
seen what the power of just setting a
net zero target has been in the uk um
sat two years ago almost and and yeah
it's just kind of completely
revolutionized business world everybody
knows that that's the goal and that's
what we need to aim for so i think
that's you know that's the best thing
that we can do and hopefully um you know
the prime minister and the uk cop team
are going to be absolutely relentless in
in campaigning for that and getting as
strong and ambitious pledges from other
countries as possible um i guess another
thing around climate finance for the
developing nations always going to be
important um and and sort of leveraging
um uh those countries into the debate
more although obviously a lot of them
have been at the forefront anyway
because a lot of them are the ones that
are already being affected mostly by
climate change and stand to be in the
future um so yeah i think hopefully you
know we we know the prime minister's
excellent at his rhetoric and hopefully
he can use that to catalyze further
support among um the developed world to
really ramp up ambition on climate
change because the uk has been a leader
um and and we are being now joined by
other nations and blocks like the eu but
um i think i think there's still a long
way to go and the uk can show how it has
decarbonized so effectively and other
nations can learn from that
and matthew
do you kind of go back to some of the
points you've earned you're making or
when it comes to have having ultimately
that international discussion with so
many countries there what do you think
is the
the real takeaway the government need to
have from it
or other on the international front i
mean look for mega i think it's about
leaning into some of the there are
things that are genuinely difficult uh
in here
uh
the role of coal uh
some of the genuinely hard to avoid uh
sectors aviation would be amongst those
and things like that carbon pricing
ferociously complex and everyone's got
an opinion on i think the key thing is
to get stuck into some of those
difficult things
ah but then
i think my view is where we and others
have got a role to play that actually if
business can help to role model some of
that international consensus and say
look here's something we can get behind
it's kind of what we were trying to do
in ahead of the g7 sort of meeting
recently in cornwall and so on i think
your business could say that yeah we're
up for this and we could work along
these lines hopefully then that gives
encouragement uh to governments of those
nations as well and if we can get stuck
into those kind of issues i think that
will make real real progress
and bib i think
sticking with obviously the the
international conversation we're heading
to
in this year of course uh you talk to
eddie a little bit about how you
differentiate between poor countries and
countries like china and china is
clearly controversial uh to many in the
tory party when it comes to what balance
borrowers would strike in uh working
with china
given uh
it's record on climate change uh you
know bringing people on side but also
there's lots of you know uh human rights
abuses also so what do you think uh the
government should or will be doing ahead
of cop but there's gonna be a lot of
focus and scrutiny and on how to go
about
yes i think it'll be tricky uh
my view which is contrary to some people
who have more extreme views of my party
on this subject is that china isn't
going anywhere we're going to have to
engage with them they're a big country
and
if we want to get anywhere close to
achieving what we need to on climate
which is a global problem not a british
problem it's a global problem then we're
going to have to have a good
relationship with them and work with
them very very closely and i know that
alex sharma
president of cop26 is doing that indeed
i am
having a conversation with some um
senior chinese people uh politicians on
this very subject in in a couple of
weeks time
so i think what we need to do is when
we're dealing with china make sure we
deal with the issue in hand and deal
with that in a frankly in a relatively
isolated specific way and when we come
to talking about human rights we should
definitely do so and i know the foreign
secretary feels very strongly about
these things and so he should as does
the prime minister but we shouldn't
allow that conversation to dominate
absolutely everything we do because if
we do that it might make us feel better
but we will
not achieve what we need to on climate
as i say this is a global problem you
know the uk
is about one to two percent of global
emissions
we will only deal with this problem
with all the technology in the world if
china and the united states
are
doing the right things and doing it in
the right time frame so
uh it's my view that we have to engage
very positively with china in this
regard that also is the case in relation
to their industry and we should use any
sort of carbon adjustment mechanism or
carbon pricing or anything like that we
should use as part of a carrot and stick
approach to say we're trying to look we
want to trade with you we want to engage
with you but you have to do it in a fair
way on the right standards and they will
have to move in that direction because
they need to export their their products
to us
eamon do you think that that's the type
of approach
government is going to have to consider
we can look at things on a very domestic
level but clearly uh you know much
larger countries have much larger carbon
footprints uh yeah are completely
crucial to this
yeah definitely and and you know one can
look at the work of say professor steve
helm who's he's really kind of led um
led the charge for carbon border
adjustments um
among other people but um but yeah i
mean that's why i come back to what i
said in my opening remarks is that you
know we can we can get to net zero and
pass ourselves on the back
but if the rest of the world isn't doing
it then then i think rightly um some of
the sort of more skeptical people of the
whole climate agenda you know i think
that is something that you sort of have
to say fair enough on um so then it's
sort of yeah incumbent upon um you know
policymakers and and all people involved
in that to come up with those solutions
which um that we can do to influence
change right around the world and i
think a carbon border adjustment
mechanism is one of those and
and interestingly i think it is one of
those policies which does unite a lot of
um different and disparate wings at
parties or westminster itself um you
know we had um dr lee and fox making the
case for them uh at cps a few weeks ago
that was followed up by an op-ed by uh
amber rudd and andrea lettson um and so
yeah i think there are lots of different
ways to approach um things like carbon
border adjustment mechanisms um so yeah
hopefully that that sort of
is a reason to be optimistic about them
um as as sort of effective tools which
we can adopt today to to to drive
decarbonization all around the world
and claire do you think uh when it comes
to i suppose making some of these things
happen we're talking about the fact it
has to be a global effort
do you think the government can lean on
industry more in a way when it comes to
uh i suppose showing other countries or
you know foreign companies that there is
a path to doing this you can rely on
people's goodwill and say well you know
look at this david ashborough
documentary um but there's a but you can
also say well actually this is something
that can be very prosperous for you as a
company and maybe industries better
place to really be able to point to
results like that
yes i mean i think industry is that is
the right tool to take to take this
forward and any encouragement from
government to do that absolutely but i
mean we host lots of visits to our power
station we've come off coal with the
first big coal fire power station to go
to bioenergy and we have lots of uh
folks from all over the world come to
our fire station and we welcome them we
put on tours we encourage that uh we we
we're very very happy to share with
government our technology and with the
poorer nations we're really up to
playing our our part in that because you
know they are part of the problem but
they're also part of the solution so i
think the more that we can work you know
the clock is ticking so we are really up
for sharing our technology and to have
that partnership with government it's
about partnership isn't it it's about
partnership with industry we're doing
some great international partnerships
with the japanese and with others we're
really really keen to make this an
international uh technology approach to
to tackling the biggest issue which is
climate change so i think it's uh
fantastic yeah
now we only got about five minutes left
so i'm going to give one question to
them then i'm going to ask everyone and
i'd just openly say you know if if there
could be one change and it doesn't want
to cop just you what you think will be
the most meaningful thing that could
happen to really kind of uh make sure
that this rhetoric about green trade
policy uh becomes you know impactful um
so if you ever start thinking about that
now but um then i just want to go to you
because why do i not get a chance to
start thinking you're also guaranteed
but you you get you get you get a
nastier question too you talked about a
stick and carrot approach um now we
talked about the carrot for the stick
but i wondered when we're talking about
holding countries responsible for
heavily polluting practices do you think
when it comes to uk trade policy
that the uk should ultimately not do
trade deals for certain countries if
they have a bad record now we know in
terms of the policy there has to be some
commitments sewn into these deals right
now but do you think it should go a bit
fairer i mean should the uk really if
it's leading by example
do deals with countries with dubious
records on this
uh i
think that you should never
rule out any option but i'd be very
reluctant to take that approach
if you
the best way in my view is that you do
trade deals but you have the right
mechanisms and obligations contained
within them
because let's take of the alternative
let's just say there's a country that
isn't playing pool they aren't doing the
right things as judged not just by the
uk but by any international standard and
we say right we're not doing a trade
deal with you okay it's not going to
stop them
doing what they're doing it's not going
to
to change that dynamic what you need to
do is do engagement with them
help them
and if if so if so
need be you might have to help
contribute to financially if they're a
poor country
is we have to make sure those countries
do the right thing when it comes to the
products they're producing for trade
because
ultimately unless you can engage with
people in that sort of positive way you
don't get anywhere so
i'd be very reluctant to take that
approach though i understand completely
why some people may think it's a good
idea i think it's it's ultimately
self-defeating okay now i'm going to go
around the panel for just a final
reflection on the most the way i
supposed to make green and global trade
in the uk uh a world leader so i'm going
to start i'm going to tell everyone now
the order we're going to go matthew
we're gonna get amen we're gonna get
claire and then bim's gonna give us our
final answer so uh matthew can you go
fast
maybe you managed to talk yourself into
getting the most thinking time after all
that's very very canny i would say look
here for me i would say look i would
actually start with unleashing the
innovation the technology and the
investments so actually you get the sort
of commercial interest and the intent
and commitment right behind it that
trade deals can be phenomenally helpful
but i think if you've got all of that
going on behind it and sort of at least
the power of business into it i think
that's the way to make real progress
and amen
okay so i've been talking about one um
acronym all all day um so i'm gonna
throw another one out there accts which
is the agreement on climate change trade
and sustainability it's an international
um initiative launched by new zealand
and the host of other countries and i
would love to see the uk joining it um
it's something which the board of trade
has recommended this trust does
and essentially two two main things it
tries to do cuts tariffs on and
non-tariff barriers on uh green goods
and services and also seeks to phase out
subsidies for polluting activities like
energy generation or agriculture
which i see no reason for the uk or any
country to be subsidizing
so so yes let's let's
try and see to join that
and then use cop26 to catalyze other
nations to do the same
brilliant thank you and claire
i'm afraid i'm going to reiterate what
matthew said enable empower business
uh yeah enable
the technologies the investment and just
watch it go just like wind power you
know it's trade will happen business
will happen if you empower um the
commercial and the technology and the
investment and it will happen
okay
then you've got your your final airtime
um
i wouldn't crap i suppose on any of the
other side you know i think that was an
interesting suggestion from eamon there
about something the government could
consider yeah i mean i'd like to think
about that i think it's very interesting
i think i'm persuaded that what we need
to really unleash private sector
investment
is a clear
you know rad model a clear capital model
for how to invest in new technologies
that everybody knows is very open
and can attract international investment
as much as domestic um because in a
couple of years if the investment has
not materialized then we can look back
and say well you said if we did this it
would work and it hasn't so i think that
is one thing we can do and on the
building side the domestic front i would
very clearly come out and reassure
millions of people across the country
that we aren't about to give them a 10
000 pound tax to replace all their
boilers overnight because i think that
at the moment is probably
you know a danger that that that people
will turn against the green agenda which
really would be very very damaging so i
think that we need to internationally we
need to get that fdi in by providing a
clear investment model and then
domestically we need to reassure people
that these changes on domestic heat and
buildings will be done with a lot of
government support
yeah i think that's a really interesting
point because as you say if
right now there's a lot of support out
there for this agenda but it doesn't
take much and you can have a situation
where actually it was a lot harder work
if the perception changes
um now with that i want to thank our
panel very much for their time today and
so thank you to bim matthew clinton and
i really appreciate you finding the time
thanks to drex for being a partner on
this event
and oh and it concludes our summit uh
road to cop 26. so i want to thank every
one of our speakers from the free panel
sessions today and just remind everyone
that if you have missed any of today's
panels or you simply want to watch one
again uh you can watch them on replay on
the website and so again can get every
single question but i think we did
manage to cover at least the breadth of
our ideas and queries coming in and
thank you very much